I want to rap right now I wanna I wanna
rap right now well we're going to hello
everyone this is my sister Jenna and I'm
Justine which camera are you looking at
I don't know this one look at this I'm
looking at the wrong camera
hello everyone nice to see you right now
we were gonna be doing a challenge but
somehow I don't even know I just like
kind of thought of it and then I was
like that would be funny and here we are
so we're not really sure what's gonna
happen we are doing a blindfold wrapping
ourselves as gifts challenge sure so
what's gonna happen is we're gonna put
our blindfolds we're gonna wrap
ourselves in gift wrapping paper and
whoever at the end of however many
minutes how many minutes you think I
have no idea gonna be a 24-hour rabid
yourself challenge three minutes three
minutes so used I think you should stay
over here wait but that's off the
picture no it's not but like and then
this is my section okay all right Wow
I'm not sure how this is gonna happen
all right well I guess we'll just put on
our blindfolds and get ready
wrapping okay may the best rapper win
you ready for this I don't know I guess
alright where's your blindfold on oh
this is so silly
set a timer for three minutes how am I
gonna wrap myself and tape myself so I
don't know what you're gonna be doing
and I don't know what I'm gonna be doing
so this puts me in a very sleep I know
there's like blindfold I don't want you
to feel like very silly predicament okay
so I got to get a good base thanks I
hope I get it
also insurance for breakfast is great I
have it we cool thanks Obama
oh my gosh I don't know where I gotta
get my toy I think I'm stuck
are you okay I had an idea in my mind I
know I think I'm out of paper
oh how big is your body Wow I'm not sure
well shoot wait a minute I think this
was easier than I thought oh wait a
minute oh no shoot oh god no I'm not a
paper we only let you enrolled genius I
know this one over here oh my god I
can't see but I feel oh nice oh wow okay
is it time now I need 20 seconds Iraq
tape myself up well your jig is what
he's like I'm taking 20 seconds okay
Nicky tell us one
I just got a wrapper
okay is it time to get back in all right
I'm good okay but how do we know who won
so what do we do so Nick did you take a
picture of us okay cuz we're gonna have
to look at them to see what happens now
[Applause]
really oh yeah
hey okay what do you want to unwrap us
yeah make you breathe
Jennifer she can't breathe wrap yeah
good yeah do you think we're weird let's
see the photo hey did my boss down on my
head
yeah what'd the bowl oh my so what I
wanted to do was I wanted to roll myself
and so then it kept rolling like uneven
so that I rolled my whole body but all I
did was roll my knee is that I was like
well I'm stuck Wow so yeah I'm not
really sure I mean I basically started
from the bottom and the know that you're
here here yeah so that's what happened
Oh yep well guys thanks for watching
this was actually surprisingly good and
uh not as difficult as I thought it was
gonna be
it's warm in there I did get warm yeah
my era was being constricted don't ever
wrap yourself as a gift in sausage you
know do you know what I did I put my bow
and here so I'd easy access to oh that's
a good idea
kept dropping the tapes I had my mouth
yeah I had it like in my pants and I
kept stabbing me I was look at this I
could have just that mysterious tape I
couldn't freaking see my tape wasn't
sticking because it was like I got you
an industrial one too yeah but I was
worried I'd hurt myself cuz I was
rolling I finally want something i won
ah they determine they determine please
help this is your action my turn ain't
Bowl well guys thanks for watching happy
holidays Merry Christmas whatever it is
that you celebrate I will see you guys
in the next video
this was a fantastic if there's any
other videos you guys would like to see
us make let us know in the comments
below also let us know who you think
can't be best rapping and this didn't
have sticky on it so I had to make my
own tape somebody is really gunning for
bonus points you can't so my joke bonus
oh I didn't even get it Oh dum dum hmm
see you later
[Music]